Guten Morgen Thomas. Hallo Tim.
Lokbuch Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertvierundvierzig vom zweiundzwanzigsten
Februar zweitausendachtzehn und ihr habt schon äh fast mitbekommen, Ninus ist heute mal nicht da, der ist mal wieder unterwegs, aber ich habe mir
Gleich zweierlei Verstärkung dazu geholt, nämlich bei mir hier im Studio mit dabei ist der Thomas, aber nicht Thomas Lohninger, wie hier so oft, sondern ich begrüße Thomas Rudel, hallo.
Hallo, natürlich hätten wir schon an der Aussprache Thomas ohne H.
Klar.
Gewaltiger Unterschied, aber auch aus Österreich.
Aber auch aus Österreich, immerhin, wir bleiben uns treu und äh ja, nicht äh direkt im Studio, sondern zugeschaltet aus Hannover äh begrüße ich den Holger Holger Bleich.
Moin, moin aus Hannover, hi.
Wie kam es zu dieser Runde? Wir haben die letzten Tage gemeinsam eine Reise unternommen, nämlich nach Brüssel, wo wir uns nicht nochmal besser kennengelernt haben, sondern sozusagen auch dem gleichen Thema nachgegangen sind. Dazu werden wir auch gleich nochmal etwas
ausführlicher berichten aber eigentlich wollten wir mit einem äh anderen Thema äh starten, nämlich der Klage
Zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung wo du ja beteiligt bist, aber äh bevor wir das vielleicht kurz machen, vielleicht von jedem von euch nochmal so ein kurzes äh Hintergrundbild, was ihr eigentlich so treibt. Thomas, du bist ja bei,
Netzpolitik Punkt org, auch mit dabei im Autorenteam. Äh seit wann eigentlich.
Mittlerweile sind's glaube ich drei Jahre bin ich mir nicht darin. Vorher war ich ja exklusiv oder Vollweichkollege von Holger äh in Hannover.
Erinnere mich noch dunkel.
Vor Unterstellung, Frechheit. Ja, wobei der Raucherbereich in der Relativ dunkel, da muss man halt draußen sitzen.
Äh ja, bin dann eben nach ähm Berlin gezogen, zum Netzpolitik Punkt Arg. Äh und ja, mache da allerhand ähm jetzt politische Themen.
Das hat das war auch der Grund, dass du nach Berlin gegangen bist sozusagen. O.
So ist es. Genau. Ja, genau. Also da ein bisschen den Horizont erweitern und äh auch äh ja eben jetzt politische Sachenberg.
Und wie und wie bist du da so zu gekommen? Also was ist so dein allgemeiner Hintergrund, dass du dich damit überhaupt auseinandersetzt mit den Themen.
Na ja gut äh grundsätzlich halt im weitesten Sinne Technik interessiert, ähm äh um das so zu formulieren, habe dann Politikwissenschaft in Wien noch studiert
äh hab
dann aber irgendwann mal beschlossen, ich mache jetzt mal was ordentliches und nicht nur in äh verrauchten Proberaumen abhängen und auf der Uni und bin dann vor, äh, nicht unbedingt das her, sechs, sieben Jahre nach Hannover zu Hause.
Ja, da brauche ich auch ein paar Jahre gehabt oder im Volumentariat gemacht und ja.
Netterweise den als Politikpunkt auch die Redaktion Verstärkung gesucht, um so ein bisschen mehr in den journalistischen Bereich zu gehen uns auf die Chance bin ich sofort drauf gesprungen.
Bis von von daher ist er weggegangen, um mehr in den journalistischen Bereich zu gehen.
Da ist so, dass sie sich gewahrt hier in einem die Warte im Mund verdreht, Frechheit. Bist du Aktivist?
Wer in den letzpolitischen Bereich zu gehen. Kleiner Witz. Ähm ja und welche Themen nimmst du dich so äh primär an bei Netzpolitik Onk.
Also ich bin ziemlich äh tief ähm äh in den Infrastrukturbereich. Ähm da habe ich mich festgebissen. Ähm also vom Breitbandausbau, Glasfaser, aber im im Allgemeinen so Regulierungspolitik ähm selbstverständlich in dem Zusammenhang ist die Netzneutralität äh sehr relevant.
Aber äh ich habe auch äh recht viel äh zu Upload-Filtern beispielsweise gemacht. Ähm generell Regulierungsfragen, Plattformregulierung, die jetzt auch demnächst immer äh mehr irgendwie aufs Tape kommt, auch langsam auch seitens der EU-Kommission.
Auch wenn die Schritte, die uns da in Brüssel präsentiert wurden, großen Teil relativ zaghaft sind. Ähm.
Um sonst im Großen und Ganzen natürlich ähm alle möglichen und unmöglichen Netzpolitischen Themen äh eben je nachdem, was halt tagesaktuell über den Twito Feed dann rüberhuscht.
Mhm. Ja und Holger, du, du bist Pochbacheise.
Ja, ja, ich bin hier, ich bin hier manchmal noch ein bisschen journalistisch aktiv. Ich versuch's zumindest.
Ja
Also ich bin, ich bin schon äh sehr lange hier, also mittlerweile fast zwanzig Jahre.
Ja, dann dann ist man dann ist man schon Urgestein, habe ich gehört.
Ja, dann ist man im Ventar quasi schon. Ich bin hier schon am Sessel festgewachsen, wenn ich nachher rausgehe
klebt er wahrscheinlich noch immer. Nein, äh nee, ich ich ändere auch immer mal wieder bisschen äh so den den Fokus und die Schwerpunkte. Wir haben ja jetzt echt ziemlich viele Freiheiten, was wir machen können und was nicht,
im Laufe der Zeit, weil ich halt auch brotloserweise Politikwissenschaft studiert habe, allerdings in Marburg und äh und auch Medienwissenschaft ähm da bin ich dann auch hier auf die Themen wissen
bisschen drauf gegangen. Aber Netzpolitik ist natürlich bei Heide kommt kommt viel vor, aber ist halt immer noch eher ein seiten Aspekt, weil wir, weil wir halt eher technikorientiert sind
leider, aber die soweit ich darf und kann, mache ich die Netzpolitischen Themen so ein bisschen, aber auch nicht alleine. Wir haben ja auch zum Beispiel in in Berlin Stefan Kreppel, der viel netzpolitisch berichtet und da unterwegs ist,
und ansonsten mache ich halt viel juristische Themen auch. Also ich betreue hier auch im, bei der CT die Rechtsrubrik
und äh so IT-Rechtsfragen und Verbraucherrechtsfragen behandele ich da auch immer ein bisschen mit. Und äh ja ich,
was Europarecht angeht oder so war ich jetzt noch.
Bin ich immer mal wieder dabei und äh habe aber immer noch zum Beispiel große Schwierigkeiten, wenn ich mal zum Beispiel ich weiß nicht, wie's dir geht Thomas, aber ein EuGH-Urteil lese, ich finde das immer wahnsinnig echt wahnsinnig anstrengend und dann merke ich immer
wenn dann die zehnte Richtlinie in einem Satz erwähnt wird, äh wie wenig ich doch Verständnis habe für europäische Gesetzgebung, deswegen fand ich das eine gute Sache, dass
wieder mal nach Brüssel eingeladen wurden, aber da kommen wir ja gleich zu.
Von von OGA-Urteilen, äh die lese ich nicht, aber ich bin schon mit dem Lesen von EU-Richtlinien ausgelastet und ich kann mir versichern, da bekommt man ebenfalls Kopfschmerzen davon.
Ja, ich weiß.
Eine Frage Anmerkung noch, also
der heiße hat also Verlag Heinz Heiser heißt er ja Heise Verlag in Hannover ist ja nicht nur jetzt so eine Macht was so überhaupt Technik, Journalismus betrifft, sondern ich fand ja auch von,
Anfang an immer eigentlich war so diese ganze juristische und netzpolitische Dimension immer schon ein fester Bestandteil, also sei es mal
explizite Stellungnahmen im CT, Edithorial, aber natürlich auch eine relativ nahe Begleitung dieser Thematiken im im News Ticker
wie eine wie nimmst du denn das so von innen heraus wahr, wie so der Verlag und die Reakteure sich da selbst äh sehen und positionieren.
Meinst du jetzt politische Ausrichtung? So ein bis.
Nee, nee, weniger. Also warum interessiert euch da? Also warum ist das sozusagen da so in der Kultur so drin und ist meine Wahrnehmung überhaupt richtig?
Deine Wahrnehmung ist auf jeden Fall richtig. Ähm ich meine, es liegt natürlich auch daran,
woher wir kommen, ne? Also ähm es sind hier unheimlich viele Leute auch, die teilweise auch gute Kontakte haben zum CCC. Ne und äh zum Beispiel Jürgen Schmidt, unser heißt Security-Chef ähm äh
äh und,
wir haben viele andere Leute, die einfach äh auch von der politischen Schiene herkommen und uns wird ja oft vorgeworfen, dass wir, dass wir teilweise ein bisschen zu einseitig und zu links über über Dinge berichten. Ich ich würde das nicht ganz so sehen. Wir sind eben auch äh,
Wir haben uns unsere Technikkritik, unsere Technik, Technik, äh, kritischen Standpunkte auch erhalten und das geht ja insbesondere in Richtung,
Schlüsselung, Überwachung und halt auch das Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat uns ja begleitet uns ja schon seit seit
zig Jahren und äh deswegen versuchen wir auch unsere oder sehen auch unsere Pflichterinnen, unsere Leser da auf dem Laufenden zu halten. Also äh und das wird sich auch nicht ändern übrigens. Also das ist ganz klare Linie
des Verlags, dass das äh weiter auch Bestandteile berichterstattung sein muss.
Ja, damit kommen wir dann vielleicht auch gleich mal zu unserem ersten
Tim Block ist jetzt äh ja noch gar nicht so lange her, da hat dann die äh Bundesregierung auf ihren letzten Metern nochmal ein Gesetz beschlossen
in äh ja wie es so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht äh auch in auf eine Antwort auf den großen Landesverrat. Skandal, wir erinnern uns an Abgrund von Landesverrat, äh
wo ähm.
Netzpolitik Org halt äh vorgeworfen wurde. Sie würden sich hier am Staat hintergehen, weil sie halt Dokumente veröffentlicht haben. Ähm dort gab es diesen.
Neun schönen Paragraphen zum Thema Datenhelerei. Ja und vor allem,
geht dem Ganzen halt natürlich auch nochmal so eine neue Initiative der Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh mit einher.
Ja jetzt gibt es eine neue Klage vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht und du bist ja einer derjenigen, die dort in der Liste der klagenden aufgeführt sind, Holger.
Genau, also das ähm die die das Verfassungsbeschwerde vermalden sehen. Ähm aber man hätte es auch klar gehör.
Ja okay, das.
Und äh ähm.
Ja, aber verständlicher, wahrscheinlich. Ähm.
Ja, also ich bin einer der Beteiligten. Genau, ich bin einer der sogenannten Beschwerdeführer, aber halt auch nicht schwerpunktmäßig, schwerpunktmäßig äh angestrengt wurde, dass äh von der,
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte von Ulf Burmeier. Ähm.
Im Moment einige Fassungslagen am Laufen haben, was sich übrigens sehr toll finde, also Gesetze oder Gesetzesvorhaben, von denen die glauben, dass sie äh dass sie die Freiheit und die Bürgerrechte einschränken, versuchen, die systematisch,
anzugreifen auf eben auf rechtmäßigen Weg, auf auf legalen Weg, nämlich mit zum Beispiel Verfassungsbeschwerden und da sind wir und in dem Fall bin ich jetzt gefragt worden, ob ich mitmache als Betroffener
und das habe ich natürlich sehr gerne gemacht äh denn ich bin bei Heise auch zuständig für die ganzen Investigativthemen, wir haben ja ein Investigativ.
Und ich recherchiere bisweilen auch mal investigativ und ähm wir hatten äh vor zwei Jahren eine ziemlich umfangreiche Recherche.
Und äh in dem Zusammenhang äh hatten wir auch zum Beispiel mussten wir rechtliche Beratungen ranziehen, mussten also auch Daten weitergehen. Und deswegen ist Ulfe auch drauf aufmerksam geworden. Also worum geht's? Es geht darum, dass äh quasi.
Im Hinterrücks würde ich mal sagen ähm mit dem Gesetzespaket zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung noch ein anderer Paragraph mit reingekommen ist. Das ist der Paragraph zweihundertzwei,
Straff äh Strafgesetzbuch und das ist der Datenhelerei Paragraph. Soll ich den mal kurz vorlesen.
Zweihundertzwei Absatz zwei Wehrdaten, die nicht allgemein zugänglich sind und die ein anderer durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat, sich oder einem anderen verschafft, einem anderen überlässt, verbreitet oder sonst zugänglich macht
um sich oder einen Dritten zu bereichern oder einen anderen zu schädigen, wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft. Wir nennen den sogenannten Anti-Visle Blowing Paragraphen, denn es geht darum, äh wenn wir
zum Beispiel über Whisleblower, über Informanten und wir fordern Informanten ja auch aktiv
auf sich an uns zu wenden und haben entsprechende Schnittstellen geschaffen. Wenn die also zu uns kommen und uns Daten geben und wir werten die aus,
können wir rechtlichen durch diesen Paragraphen die Plädoyer kommen, nämlich dann zum Beispiel wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel wir haben technische Probleme bei der Auswertung oder Verifizierung von irgendwelchen,
die wir bekommen und ziehen externe Beratung oder wollen externe Beratung haben. Zum Beispiel fragen wir Linus, ne? Kannst du uns da helfen,
wenn wir Linus diese Daten geben machten wir beziehungsweise macht Linus sich strafbar, wenn er mit diesen Daten hantiert, wenn er sie sich nur anguck.
Nach dem Paragraphen, denn der Paragraph hat eine Ausnahme
äh die sagt, wenn man beruflich, journalistisch zugange ist mit diesen Daten rein beruflich, dann darf man sie sich angucken, man darf sie aber eben nicht weitergeben an Dritte äh und schon gar nicht an Leute weitergeben, die nicht berufsmäßige Journalisten sind
und das ist natürlich erstens total schwammig, denn was ist ein berufsmäßiger Journalist? Thomas bist du ein berufsmäßiger Journalist.
Diese Debatte wurde vor circa zehn Jahren abgeschlossen, hoffe ich. Au.
Nee, nee, die wird, die ist eben dadurch wieder aufgemach.
Also es ist die große Frage, ob jetzt äh ab wann ist denn ein Blogger? Ein Journalist ist er dann ist er dann Journalist, wenn er über Affiliate-Links oder oder ähm Werbebänder in seinem Blog seinen Blog refinanziert, ist er dann schon profimäßig unterwegs. Man weiß es nicht,
Das ist das wird dann wahrscheinlich erst auch in dem Fall wieder die Rechtsprechung dann irgendwann erklären in zig Jahren. Aber so lange ist das unklar.
Und um das noch weiterzuführen, das größere Problem an der Geschichte ist noch, die geht einher.
Mit einem anderen Begrafen, Paragraph in der Strafprozessordnung, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das wisst. Es gibt
für uns Journalisten, für Redaktionen aus gutem Grund, erstens ein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht
Das heißt, wir können unsere Quellen schützen, wir müssen die nicht nennen, auch wenn äh wenn äh die Strafverfolgung uns dazu auffordert, können wir unsere Quellen daheim halten. Äh und vor allem gibt es auch ein Durchsuchungsverbot.
Eine Ausnahme, äh dass der der Hausdurchsuchungsmöglichkeiten für Strafverfolgungsbehörden äh wenn es darum geht, äh an,
Quellen zu kommen, die uns Informanten gegeben haben. Das heißt, sie können nicht einfach zu uns reinrennen und können sagen, äh hier ihr habt doch über, ihr habt doch geschrieben, ihr habt das von irgendeiner Quelle und äh wir wollen dieses Material haben,
deswegen durchsuchen wir mal bei euch in der Redaktion. Das geht nicht. Da gibt's ja auch diese berühmte Cicero-Geschichte und so.
Und jetzt gibt es in Paragraph siebenundneunzig der Strafprozessordnung eine Ausnahme, die nebenher noch eingeführt wurde, das heißt nämlich wenn es äh.
Datenhelerei geht, gemäß Paragraph oder um über Datenhillerei, gewonnene Datengemäß Paragraph zweihundertzwei, der Strafgesetzbuches.
Dann darf doch durchsucht werden. Das ist das eigentliche Problem, dass da wird das Beschlagnahmeverbot aufgehoben in dem Moment.
Also auch bei Journalisten.
Auch bei Journalisten, das heißt, äh, wir laufen jetzt in Gefahr, wenn wir sagen, wir haben diese Information aus äh aus einer Quelle, wir haben diese Dateien, aus einer bestimmten Quelle, die wir nicht nennen. Die haben wir zugespielt bekommen,
kann eine straffe Verwirkungsbehörde gegebenenfalls sagen. Äh wir brauchen wir brauchen dieses äh dieses Material, dem wir sagen, wir geben's ihnen nicht, dann können sie kommen und sich's holen. Und das ist neu.
Diese diese Brisanz von diesen gerade von diesen von der Ausnahme des Beschlagnahmeverbots, es war vielen Journalisten überhaupt nicht klar bis wir denen das mal erklärt haben damals ich war auch in Berlin als wir die was uns klar vorgestellt haben. Äh,
Reporter ohne Grenzen, da ist beinahe der Raum geplatzt, weil das ist wirklich tatsächlich auf Rieseninteresse gestoßen, was wir da eigentlich,
was wir da als Agrade eingereicht haben und viele ganz viele Journalisten haben völlig erstaunt in den Kopf geschüttelt und das Waidingen überhaupt nicht klar, dass es sowas gib
Neuerdings. Es ist eingeführt schon zweitausendfünfzehn. Wir haben das zwei Jahre später zweitausendsiebzehn mal erklärt im Rahmen dieser Pressekonferenz und da ist vielen wirklich die Kinnlade runtergeklappt. Das das ist, dass es sowas gib.
Und wirklich ganz irgendwie verdeckt eingeführt im Zuge der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Oder neuerdings neuerdings der Mindestspeicherfrist, meine.
Ja. Aber genau diese Sorge hatten wir da im Zusammenhang mit der der Landesverratsafferien dann jetzt,
Punkt org Reduktion, weil dort unters Feier eigentlich noch bevor die VDS äh neu tatsächlich dann auch vom Bundestag äh abgesegnet wurde, wenn ich mir nicht irre. Dass da tatsächlich möglicherweise irgendwelche Ermittlungsbehörden, Verfassungsschutz, wie auch immer, daher kommt
und äh das ganze Büro auf den Kopf stellt, ja.
Hm, genau oder und eben nicht nur einer Türkei, die direkt betroffen waren, sondern ja, man kann ja nicht wissen, wo sich sein Material verste.
Was auch was auch schlimm ist wirklich, wir haben das ja hier auch schon öfter erlebt, ne? Das ähm
wenn man von kundigen Strafverfolgungsbehörden ausgeht, die die wissen ja zum Beispiel, dass wir das Material, was wir hier liegen haben, wir würden es ja nie unverschlüsselt hier liegen haben. Und also äh,
ich habe habe aktuell jetzt auch an der Investikativgeschichte gearbeitet und wenn ich da Material hatte, das liegt natürlich hier nur verschlüsselt und ich die würden würden eh nicht drankommen. Und wenn wir denen es sagen würden, dann würden die auch wieder gehen, weil ne, würde ich mal hoffen, würde ich mal tippen, denke ich mal,
Aber es gibt einfach auch viele äh viele ähm Strafermittler
keine Ahnung, vertutten Blasen haben. Wir kommen, wir hatten das Beste war mal wirklich, äh
eines Morgens hat bei uns der Justiz äh ähm kamen Anrufe aus der Zentrale, äh also unten am Empfang an den Justizjahr
kommen Sie mal bitte runter, Herr Heidrich, da möchte jemand was von uns und dann stand da wegen einem Furenbeitrag auf heiße Online stand da der Staatsschutz.
Sie haben gesagt, wir würden gerne heiße Online mitnehmen.
Dann hat und dann hat unser Justizjahr erstmal irgendwie sehr lange gebraucht, um denen zu erklären, dass halt so online kann hier ist, sondern heiße Online in Frankfurt steht in einem Rechenzentrum, wenn sie es also mitnehmen wollten, dann müssten sie jetzt nach Frankfurt fahren. Die standen aber schon mit dem LKW da.
Wegen einem, wegen einem Forumbeitrag, der an wo angeblich äh verfassungsfeindliches äh äh Zeugtum stand. Ich meine, es war eine andere Zeit. Mittlerweile steht in jedem zweiten Forum Beitrag Verfassung.
Schon zehn Jahre her oder so, aber.
So was passiert und wenn du an solche Leute redest, die zögern dann auch nicht irgendwie mit dem LKW vorzufahren und dann halt irgendwie mal alle Rechner mitzunehm.
Ich finde Jörg Heidrick hat einen Test machen sollen, die sind vorne äh einen Tag ausdrucken und sie mit übergeben sollen. Wer weiß, was dann pass.
Hätte einfach das ganze Forum ausdrücken mü.
Ja wahrscheinlich, ja.
Na ja, das ist lief dann schlussendlich darauf raus, dass der dass wir den äh den die Nutzerdaten gegeben haben. Dann waren sie auch zufrieden. Aber die haben halt nicht gewusst, dass man das kann.
Na ja.
Die wussten nicht, dass meine Webseite nicht in den LKW einladen kann.
So ungefähr. Also es ist wirklich abstrus an wem er da manchmal gerät beendet wird. Also es gibt natürlich,
ich möchte das jetzt auch nicht falsch verstanden wissen. Es gibt natürlich sehr fege Strafermittler äh und einen Ermittlungsbetten, aber es gibt halt auch das äh das umgekehrte.
Ja und vor allem gibt es natürlich auch äh nicht ganz so
fähige oder nicht gut so äh technisch ausgestattete äh Journalisten, die vielleicht unter Umständen sich wirklich mit sensitiven Material auseinandersetzen, aber eben nicht die Fähigkeit und auch nicht diesen Automatismus haben. Alles äh entsprechend zu verschlüsseln und die sind natürlich dann solchen Angriffen
schutzlos ausgeliefert.
Ja, hast du recht? Ja.
Vielleicht eine Sache, die noch noch äh ein bisschen klarstellen möchte, äh falls das missverständlich war, Eingangs äh ich glaube jetzt mal nicht, dass äh die Neueinführung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh auf die Landesverratssoffire an sich zurückzuführen ist
das ist das ein Gespenst, das ständig wiederkommt, da versuchen europaweit Regierungen trotz einschlägiger GH-Urteile äh diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung
dem ein oder anderen Weg wieder einzuführen. Äh Landesverrat ist aber ein ein gutes, anschauliches Beispiel, äh wo sich sowas tatsächlich dann auswirken könnte, ganz konkret zwischen Journalisten. Ähm wenn eben tatsächlich sensibiles Material in Reduktionen liegt,
und man dann sich entweder sei es jetzt irgendwie rechtlicher äh äh Info oder jetzt irgendwie mit einem bezahlten Rechtsanwalt irgendwie ähm
zur Aussprache zu halten oder technische Hintergrundinfos benötigt und auch wirklich diese Daten dann weitergibt.
Dann wird es eben ganz gefährlich und das ist immer der Grund, äh warum äh es jetzt nicht Netzpolitik und Drag als Gesamtes, aber äh mein Kollege Andre Meister, der die entsprechenden Artikel damals veröffentlicht hat und mein äh der Chefredakteur Markus Beckedal
auch an dieser Klage beteiligt sind und die auch zu einem guten Teil eben aus unseren Geldern dann finanziert wird.
Ja, man muss auch dazu sagen, also es ist wirklich äh eine eine Industrieliste von Beschwerdeführern, die äh die da gemeinsam sind. Also es sind natürlich Markus, genau und Andre.
Ich und mein Kollege Jürgen Schmidt
Ähm wir beide arbeiten hier halt am ehesten investigativ im Verlag und haben weiter auch entsprechende Erfahrungen schon gemacht und deswegen war das auch ganz wertvoll, dass wir, dass wir da dabei sind
aber es sind halt auch solche Leute wie zum Beispiel Harry Seppelt, das ist der, der die ganzen Dopingrecherchen
macht bei bei der ARD ne und äh,
und äh wer wer ist noch dabei, wenn man genau Peter Hornung ist zum Beispiel noch dabei, das der ist vom NDR und äh hat da zum Beispiel die Panama Papers gemacht
also war dabei bei der Panapa und Panaba Papers Enthüllung
ist halt jetzt auch ähm Dieselskandal immer vorne mit dabei, wenn's um investigative Geschichten geht und äh das sind halt alles Leute, die wirklich was zu verlieren haben, wenn zum Beispiel äh,
klar wird, dass sich Informanten nicht mehr wirklich äh ohne ohne große Risiken an sie wenden können, dann verlieren wir einfach auch Geschichten und dann verliert auch die Öffentlichkeit, weil eben solche Geschichten dann eben nicht mehr an die Öffentlichkeit kommen.
Und Reporter ohne Grenzen ist natürlich auch.
Und Reporter ohne Grenzen natürlich klar, ja? Und äh äh finde ich auch sehr sehr gut, dass die sich angeschlossen haben als Organisation.
Wie ist jetzt so eure Argumentation? Also verweist ihr einfach nur so auf die originale äh also auf die äh auf die,
originale Gesetzgebung im Grundgesetz und sagt, hier, das passt ja nicht oder wie geht ihr daran.
Ihr werdet, also wir äh gehen ganz bewusst und deswegen ist es auch übrigens beim ersten Senat gelandet von beim äh Bundesverfassungsgericht und nicht beim Zweiten. Wir gehen ganz bewusst äh auf die Pressefreiheit und auf die Meinungsfreiheit.
Also kurz den Unterschied zwischen erster, zweiter Senat mal erläutern.
Äh alles was Presserecht äh was Pressesachen angeht und Meinungsfreiheits äh äh klagen, die landen vom ersten Senat und der zweite Senat ist, glaube ich, eher für Wirtschaftsfragen und so zuständig. Äh und.
Beim ersten Senat hatten wir oder äh also ich weiß es nur von Ulf Burmeier, ähm der ja auch äh federführend mit dabei ist. Ähm.
Er hat schon gehofft, dass wir zum ersten Senat kommen, das kann man nicht irgendwie beeinflussen, aber beim ersten Senat sah er zumindest äh unsere unsere ähm Belange besser aufgehoben als beim zweiten Sinne. Aber ich bin da beim Fastensgericht jetzt auch nicht so tief drin.
Also es geht halt um Artikel fünf Grundgesetz, es geht um um die Pressefreiheit und äh
um den Schutz von journalistischer Recherche von journalistischen äh Möglichkeiten und wir sehen halt äh uns in unseren Möglichkeiten eingeschränkt durch äh durch diesen zweihundertzwei
äh frei zu arbeiten.
Und ähm das ist ja dann auch relativ zügig angenommen worden.
Genau, das ist äh es ist angenommen worden und äh im Moment ist der Status. Wir sind ja da in einer in einer Runde mit mehreren Fassungsbeschwerden gegen die Vorzeitenspeicherung, also es wird alles mögliche angegriffen. Ähm wir haben jetzt Nachricht bekommen, dass.
Unsere Verfassungsbeschwerde weitergeleitet wurde, das heißt.
Im Moment liegt sie zum Beispiel mit der Bitterumstellungnahme beim Bundestag,
Beim Bundesrat, bei der Bundesregierung, insbesondere beim äh Bundesministerium der Justiz und beim Innenministerium,
auch bei den Landesregierungen, alle haben jetzt die Möglichkeit bis zum einunddreißigsten März Stellung zu beziehen zu der zu der Verfassungsbeschwerde.
Das heißt, das musst du wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall auch noch diese ähm wie heißt die unsere Bundesregierung jetzt äh offiziell geschäftsführend, genau. Ja, ich wollte gerade vorl.
Müssen sich jetzt, äh, ja, die müssen sich natürlich trotzdem mit solchen Dingen umschlagen, die Frage ist, mit welcher Werf und welcher Intensität dieses grade machen, weil die haben, glaube ich, gerade ein bisschen andere Probleme.
Müssen heute irgendwie erstmal eine neue Regierung zustande bringen. Und äh ob die bis zum einunddreißigsten März da ist und ob die sich als allererstes damit beschäftigt, also aber natürlich wird das eine Stellungnahme geben, ist ja klar. Es gibt
gibt ja, es gibt ja genügend Sachbearbeiter da.
Ja, ist auch noch nicht ganz klar, ob der äh Justizminister der gleiche bleiben wird, aber der aktuelle hatte auf jeden Fall mit zu verantworten.
Der Aktuelle hat's mir zu verantworten. Genau, also maßgeblich mit im wahrsten Sinne des.
Ähm und das ist war ja, war ja auch noch so ein Ding, ne? Thomas, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr beide könnt euch wahrscheinlich noch dran erinnern, wie das damals zustande gekommen ist. Das war ja im Endeffek.
Meiner meiner Beobachtung nach zumindest,
es gab ja irgendwie keine großen Notwendigkeit, dann hat die CDU irgendwie ein bisschen Druck gemacht auf Gabriel und dann hat Gabriel zu Maß, der noch ein glühender äh äh noch ein
glühender Verteidiger der Grundrechte war und gesagt hat, mit mir keine VDS hat auf Maß so lange eingebirgt, bis Mars auf einmal gesagt hat, na ja, die Vorortsdatenspeicherung werden also nicht für sechs Monate machen, sondern nur für drei Monate oder viel.
Kürzer ist es ja eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht und dann ging er ging ja das ganze Prozedere los.
Uns zwar ziemlich über Nacht eigentlich. Äh also.
Ziemlich über Nacht und dann gab es da, da gab es doch noch diese ähm was war das eine
wie, wie hieß das nochmal der Parteikonvent von der SPD, da da war das ja ziemlich spitze auf Knopf, ne? Ob die, ob der Kondent nicht dagegen stimmt und ob da nicht die äh die ganze Regierung eigentlich dagegen stimmen müsste, aber
ähm das hat das hatte, da hatte Gabriel Dia noch eingenordet irgendwie. Na ja.
Dann auch noch zusätzlich fragwürdig ist, dass dann also die die Vorsatzensprechung an sich ja schon sehr fragwürdig ist, äh wenn man sich die europäische Gesetzgebung ansieht und das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass in Deutschland versucht wird, äh
entsprechende Maßnahmen einzuleiten. Äh da wurden dann wirklich tatsächlich noch Paragraphen reingemogelt, wie eben genau dieser dieser ganze Geschichte mit der Datenhelerei.
Die damit eigentlich nichts zu tun haben sollte. Also da bin ich auch schon sehr auf der Argumentation der geschäftsführenden Bundesregierung gespannt äh vom Verfassungsgericht,
wie sie das dann irgendwie ähm so also eben das sind Sachen, die eigentlich miteinander nichts zu tun haben, wo du nichts miteinander zu tun haben sollten.
Ja, also wir wir sind zumindest jetzt äh ich weiß nicht wie Markus das sieht. Ähm also ich bin da jetzt im Moment sehr zuversichtlich. Also wenn.
Ja, ne? Also ähm wir wir wussten ja gar nicht, wo es hingeht. Ich habe da natürlich auch wenig äh wenig Erfahrung mit. Also wir wollen halt eine Klarstellung haben.
Ähm wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht sieht. Das ist das, was wir uns erhofft haben. Aber wenn es tat, wenn wenn wir tatsächlich dazu kommen, dass äh dass wir den, dass der zwohundertzwei gekipp.
Dann würde ich hier nicht nur eine Flasche Sekt aufmachen, da würde ich mich wirklich sehr freuen. Und das ist wäre auch nicht das, was wir in unseren künstlichen Träumen uns äh äh erhofft hätten. Aber
Es wäre toll, wenn's ein klares Urteil geben würde.
Und und also vorsichtig optimistisch äh deswegen, weil einerseits ist ja nichts selbstverständliches, dass man mit seiner Beschwerde respektive Klage auch tatsächlich vor dem Gericht landet. Das ist schon mal ein ganz wichtiger, großer Schritt. Und zweitens, ähm, eben, dass es dann doch verhältnismäßig schnell gegangen ist,
und dass wir vor dem Senat eins gelandet sind. Also das sind so Sachen, an denen kann man ablesen, dass ähm dass dann möglicherweise doch zu unseren Gunsten ausgehen, der Wochengurt wird sehen.
Es geht zumindest, es geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung, das finde ich sehr gut.
Wenn die Stellungnahme äh jetzt Ende März abgeliefert werden soll, was bedeutet das dann so üblicherweise für den zeitlichen Fortgang? Also gehst du davon aus, dass es noch so alles im ersten Halbjahr durch ist.
Nee, nicht im ersten Halbjahr. Wir hoffen aufs zweite Halbjahr. Also wir hoffen, dass es zweitausendachtzehn noch durch ist,
deutet schon einiges darauf hin, wir sind auf der Agenda vom Verfassungsgericht die haben ja gerade ihren Jahresplan rausgebracht und da stehen wir mit drin, dass das in diesem Jahr verhandelt werden soll und abgeschlossen werden soll und da müssen wir halt mal gucken
also es ist ja, ne, also wenn du überlegst, wenn du dir die Agenda mal ganz anguckst, ist schon Wahnsinn, was die da, was die da durchpeitschen müssen pro Jahr an Verfassungsbeschwerden.
Und allein bei uns, ne? Also wenn wir jetzt die Vorzeitensprechung mal zusammennehmen, sind sehr viele Beschwerden, also Kanzlei äh Herting hat hat
einige Paragraphen in der VDS angegriffen dann natürlich die Klage von Digitalgurer, Digitalcourage, ähm, Starosik.
Das sind die alle sind jetzt zusammengefasst zu als als Klagen gegen dieses Gesetzespaket, Vorratsdatenspeicherung einschließlich Datenhehlerei und die werden dann mit Sicherheit auch zusammen entschieden werden.
Sie müssen sich aber mit allen vier noch intensiv auseinandersetzen.
Die sind jetzt alle, man muss auch dazu sagen, es ist ja nicht nur unsere, die ist ja schon ziemlich äh groß. Äh das sind alle vier äh Klageschriften, die jetzt weitergeleitet worden und äh da haben die auch einiges zu tun mit der A.
Bist du auch kein.
Mir auf das Thema. Ja, ich meine, das war ja nun schon über die Jahre ein Dauerbrenner und bisher hat sich eigentlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Sagen wir mal.
Doch zumindest sehr kritisch geäußert, ja, teilweise ablehnen, teilweise halt immer so diese na ja so ganz verbieten, wo man's jetzt äh äh doch nicht und und das folgenden Voraussetzungen ist das vielleicht möglich
was natürlich auch immer wieder diese neuen Anläufe.
Du meinst jetzt die Anlassunabhängige Speicherung, ne? Ne? Mhm.
Ja, aber also die Grenzen sind schon klar gesetzt, denke ich. Und äh insbesondere auch Europarechtlich klargesetzt, versucht. Der EuGH hat das sehr eindeutig entschieden und ich kann überhaupt nicht verstehen, warum man jetzt äh unbedingt dann nochmal einen Anlauf.
Bin mir ehrlich gesagt also auch bei den drei anderen Klagen relativ sicher, dass es das wird,
Natürlich kommt die VDS, also ich sie ist ja jetzt sowieso verwaltungstechnisch ausgesetzt gerade, ne? Also ich finde die ja nicht statt, obwohl sie eigentlich schon lange in Kraft ist. Äh und das ich glaube nicht, dass jemand in also dass es tatsächlich jemals zu einer Vollzeitsprechung noch kommt. Und es ist,
meiner meiner Ansicht nach wie vor unnötig und die Bundesregierung hat immer noch nicht irgendwie quantifiziert und äh noch keine vernünftigen Argumente gebracht,
warum man sie unbedingt braucht,
Also in in dem Bereich schwere Straftaten und Terror, um den es ja immer gehen soll, aber in der Argumentation ähm gibt es natürlich genügend Mittel und Wege sich an der Vorortsdatenspeicherung zu entziehen. Wenn man will und das machen die ja auch.
Quatsch alles, also meine Begriffe.
Schöner Satz, den man Ort of Context nehmen kann, die Bundesregierung hat immer noch nicht erklärt, warum man sie eigentlich braucht.
Du ich meine, ich höre ja viel Podcasten, du arbeitest aber hoffentlich nicht mit Soundbist, oder? Oder machst du das.
Sowas würde ich doch niemals tun. Gut, ähm gibt's noch irgendeinen letzten Satz, den du da noch nachreichen möchtest?
Nö, ich habe doch gerade einen schönen geliefert, oder.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
VDS muss weg.
Ja, VDS muss weg, dem kann ich mich auch vorbehaltlos anschließen, weil äh es gibt
wirklich im Strafverfolgungsbereich genügend andere Möglichkeiten, um den wenn man wirklich täterhaft habt werden will, Stichwort Quickfees zum Beispiel. Es geht immer um die Anlassunabhängigkeit und das äh eine Anlassunabhängigkeit ist ist immer, finde ich höchstproblematisch verfassungsrechtlich.
Vielleicht auch noch so ein ein Halbsatz äh noch dazu, also selbst die äußerst fragwürdige Rechtsrechtsrechts-Extremregierung in Österreich, äh die ja jetzt auch kürzlich ein Überwachungspaket äh vorgelegt hat,
Ähm wenn ich mich jetzt nicht also äh Quickfreeze hat sich so als Kompromiss sozusagen durchgesetzt in dieser ganzen VDS ähm ähm äh Debatte. Bedeut.
Im Sinne von man speichert nicht die ganze Zeit, sondern nur auf Zuruf.
Exakt uns waren.
Anders abhängig.
Anders abhängig, genau. Also sprich wenn uns zwar natürlich eben Trichter vorbehaltet oder je nachdem wie das im Einzelnen Mitgliedland, äh, dann ja ausgehandelt ist. Aber nicht einfach so einfach wirklich verdachtsunabhängig, massenhaft äh auf Vorrat,
Das ist nämlich die. Eben das ist der entscheidende Unterschied.
Ja, warte mal, gibt es eigentlich Thomas? Gibt es im Moment äh innerhalb der EU-Staaten, die eine Vorratszeitensprechung haben, ja, ne. Die Briten haben doch, glaube ich, oder? Ich ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt glaube, ich weiß nicht, das glaube ich gar nicht. Ja, noch, noch EU. Tim.
Ich glaube schon, ja, ja. Ja, Tim ist schuld.
Bei den Briten wäre ich zumindest nicht überrascht, wenn sie eine haben, selbst wenn's.
Nun gut, kommen wir zum äh unserem Reiseteil,
wie schon eingangs äh erwähnt, waren wir ja alle ähm in ähm Brüssel diese Woche Montag Dienstag auf Einladung der EU-Kommission
Dort äh gab's eine ganz äh interessant zusammengestellte äh Gruppe von.
Journalisten und solchen, die sich nicht wehren können, so genannt zu werden. Ähm unter an.
Sehr lustig das, ich fand es sehr lustig, dass sie, dass sie das immer digital Journalisten genommen haben. Ich erkannte diesen Begriff bis dahin gar nicht.
Ja. Na ja gut, der Anlass war ja auch so ein bisschen das Werben um ihren Plan rund um den Digital äh Single Market.
Ich habe auch so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, Digitaljournalisten triff,
das jetzt eigentlich irgendwie, also eigentlich natürlich erstmal nicht, aber sie versuchen natürlich damit was zu sagen, so, ne? Und ob sie damit jetzt sagen, das sind die, die mehr so sich mit digitalen Themen äh,
beschäftigen, also man hält ja auch Netzpolitik sagen können.
Ganz gut so, äh wobei es jetzt, das muss man dazu sagen, jetzt nicht nur Online-Leute waren, sondern es waren halt auch Vertreter äh süddeutsche Zeitungen, FaZ war dabei, ne?
Also ich fand's eben eine recht ausgewogene Mischung oder vielleicht jetzt gar nicht ausgewogen, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber auf jeden Fall eine gute,
Punktemischung, also von Podcastern, von sozusagen klassischen Printmedien, wie der Wirtschaftswoche oder bei FAZ. Äh bis zu Blogs ähm äh im Experiate Punkt Park. Äh
CT natürlich für das Feld natürlich auch noch und unter, bringt uns also Magazinjournalismus.
War auch mit dabei äh bekannter Youtuber, den wir hier auch schon mal bei LMP zweihundert zu Gast hatten,
Also ja, also das war fand ich irgendwie eine ganz nette äh Truppe und äh offenbar war man auch ganz überrascht auf Seiten der EU-Kommission, dass dann auch so viele die Einladungen angenommen haben, die haben wohl etwas breiter gestreut, als sie dachten, dass sie dann tatsächlich Zusagen bekommen.
Räume, die Meetingräume waren auf jeden Fall dann immer recht gut gefüllt und stießen auf,
Überraschung hat sich so den Eindruck bei den Kommissaren, wenn sie äh also nicht, dass ich das komplett hinten übergekippt sind, aber es fiel irgendwie auf, dass immer so ein, na ja, oh, hier ist aber voll.
Und dann hat das einerseits aber andererseits äh zumindest naja, was was die Kommissare betrifft, äh war schon,
und zu so leichte Verwundungen zu spüren. Nee, Moment einmal, äh, da werde ich jetzt wirklich im Detail äh gefragt, zu irgendwelchen Positionen, die ich nicht so wirklich äh verteidigen kann oder nicht weiß, wie ich sie verteidigen soll
weil dadurch doch sehr viel teilwissen da an die Oberfläche gekommen ist.
Das hat es natürlich aber auch sehr spannend gemacht zu diskutieren, das hat man ja auch dann mit der Justizkommissarin gesehen, dass da gab's eben so ein so ein relativ hitziges Hin und Her irgendwie und dann bist du, glaube ich, ein Köbinetschef oder so aufgesprungen ist und meinte, okay, sie muss jetzt los, zum nächsten Termin.
Und sie hat dann gemeint so, ne, das ist viel spannender, das ist viel, viel interessanter, ja, genau. Was irgendwie auch Obstruktion,
war, weil äh sie ist dann nicht wirklich auf die Fragen eingegangen. Also es hat auch so nicht wirklich was genutzt. Aber es halt eben doch spannend, äh da so das war dann oft mehr Gespräch als irgendwie so frontal äh belehr.
Vielleicht sollte man den Rahmen nochmal kurz äh genauer abstecken. Also wir sind da alle am Montag hingeflogen äh früh aus verschiedenen äh Städten mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig angekommen. Das gibt wohl der Brüsseler Flugplan ganz ordentlich Herrchen. Nehmen wir mal an, daraufhin ist er auch optimiert.
Und ähm ja dann haben wir uns da äh getroffen und es ging dann am frühen Nachmittag äh dann los und man hatte halt so am laufenden Meter.
Meetings, drei davon waren tatsächlich mit Kommissaren von den wie viel sind's? Fünfundzwanzig oder.
Achtundzwanzig oder.
Zwanzig. Ähm.
Jetzt sollten wir nochmal kurz erklären, was Kommissare sind.
Genau, die Kommissare sind ja quasi die, die in Anführungsstrichen Regierung, äh, Europas ausmachen, also die sozusagen die Kommission zusammensetzen, ne? Und äh das ist halt relativ paritätisch aus Mitgliedsländern besetzt und wir sind halt mit denen
in Kontakt gekommen, die ähm sagen wir mal jetzt unseren Themen noch,
Ja, am meisten mit zu tun haben, ne? Äh das waren dann in der Reihenfolge einerseits der Andros äh Ansipp, dieser essenische äh Politiker,
der halt der eigentliche Kommissar ist für den äh digitalen Binnenmarkt.
Dann äh sind wir äh zusammengekommen mit der Maria Gabriel. Die ist ja die Nachfolgerin von Günther Oettinger geworden,
Also die EU-Kommissarin für digitale Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft, ja? Also da gab's ja schon immer so etwas,
skurrile Überschneidung, man macht immer so alles so den Eindruck, als ob das alles so ein bisschen doppelt äh besetzt ist und man nicht so genau weiß, wer jetzt eigentlich wofür wirklich äh zuständig ist und dann,
als Drittes die Vera Jurova, die ähm.
Tschechische Politikerin, die ist, wie heißt das offiziell äh,
Justiz, genau für Justiz, Verbraucherschutz, Gleichstellung, äh dafür ist sie äh zuständig und hat dann mehr so den Schwerpunkt, Datenschutzgrundverordnung und deren Umsetzung.
Und Uploadfilter und äh Kampf gegen ähm Terrorismus auf Online-Plattformen.
Man ja eh das Gefühl, dass irgendwie alle auch nicht den.
Können wir glaube ich noch darauf.
Genug davon betonen konnten, wie, wie, wie, also das Terrorwort, das fiel äh dann doch sehr oft, ne.
Uploadfilter ebenfalls.
Außerdem gab es noch ähm,
auch einen kleinen Bereich, wo es Hintergrundgespräche gab mit Parlamentsvertretern, auch wenn die Kommission hier ganz klar im Mittelpunkt stand
und ja und vor allem sind wir wie zwischen den beiden Hauptgebäuden hin und her gehetzt, das gehört euch nicht vorstellen, was das für ein Stress war. Weil man wirklich jedes Mal, wenn man wieder in das andere Gebäude muss und wir mussten wirklich,
Ping Pong, eine Veranstaltung hier, eine Veranstaltung da, die ganze Zeit hin und her und jedes Mal wieder durch diese Security.
Du kannst ja mal kurz beschreiben, dass diese Security heißt, heißt da, ich,
Also finde ich noch krasser als am Flughafen deutlich krasser. Also das heißt du musst erstmal durch durch durch eine erste Schleuse quasi, wo du dann, wo dann deinen Ausweis zeigen musst und äh die Tasche öffnen musst. Und dann geht es halt los wie äh wie am Flughafen auch, ne? Also X-Ray Scanner und äh
alles reinlegen, ständig Jacke aus, Jacke an, Laptop raus aus der Tasche, Laptop rein in die Tasche. Wir haben uns da also irgendwann mal, haben wir einen Spaß draus gemacht, dann haben wir einen kleinen Wettbewerb gemach,
um unsere Rekorde zu brechen, wie schnell man den Gürtel außen wieder anzieht.
Aber es war ja wirklich ein Stundenrhythmus, ne? Das war schon echt ein bisschen nervig, dass wir, dass wir ständig äh zwischen den Gebäuden hin und her springen mussten. Aber natürlich auch Verständnis für die. Wir hatten ja, stand ja immer dran. Was war das? Äh.
Ich weiß nicht was Yellow ist glaube ich eins nach Grün oder sowas.
Also ich interpretiere das auch als Ampelsystem, das heißt mittlere und was natürlich auch im Straßenbild permanent präsent war, waren hochbewaffnete Amte-Terroreinheiten oder was auch immer es genau für für Behörden sind auf jeden Fall militaristisch aussehende Leute.
Es ist ja diese Woche noch ein Gipfel, ne? Diese Woche ist.
Es kommt dann irgendwann mal genau, ja. Also es ist schon so also ich weiß jetzt eben auch nicht, wie die Sicherheitslage in Brüssel ist.
Belgien aussieht und dann gibt's noch diesen Gipfel.
Denke ich auch, ja.
Also äh denkbar, dass das vollkommen bericht.
Ja, nach den Terror.
Aber trotzdem äh es ist doch ungewöhnlich ständig äh über äh eine militarisierte Gesellschaft zu stolpern und äh dann noch eben diese Sicherheitschecks permanent im Stundentakt über sich ergehen zu lassen, ja.
Ja, war kein Spaß. Es war vor allem auch ein bisschen absurd, weil man hätte ja nun wirklich auch mühelos da mal jemanden äh abstellen können. Da hätten sie deutlich weniger Arbeit mit uns gehabt, aber äh
da konnte dann auch die Presseabteilung so recht nicht durchdringen zu der Security Abteilung beziehungsweise hatte nicht genug Vorlauf gehabt, dass äh mal zu checken. Na ja, wie auch immer
sind am Rande nur Details, auch wenn's natürlich dazu beigetragen hat, dass man dann doch noch ein bisschen äh erschöpfter und ermatteter war, als wenn man jetzt einfach mal.
Jetzt hätte man ja auch mal problemlos alles in einem Haus abfeiern können, aber egal. Trotzdem war das schön, dass sie überhaupt diesen Aufwand getrieben haben. War das so dein,
Eindruck Holger von von dem wie dann die Kommission und äh unsere Gesprächspartner uns gegenüber aufgetreten sind.
Ja, sehr unterschiedlich. Also ich finde, Ansipp ist sehr im Allgemeinen geblieben. Also und ähm also Ansiep redet, glaube ich, sehr gerne und sehr viel. Und hat ja auch, hat ja auch deutlich überzogen.
Das hat ja, hat ja auch schon seinen Mitarbeiter, der vorher reinkam, schon drauf hingewiesen. Wir sollen ihn ruhig unterbrechen.
Ich bin auf das Angebot, dankens zurückgekommen.
Dann worauf er für sich bezogen.
Was ich, was ich interessant fand, ist ja, dass äh teilweise haben sich die Themen ja überschnitten zwischen den äh drei drei bei den drei Gesprächen mit den Kommissaren, also thematisch doch deutliche Ähnlichkeiten, aber es waren so deutlich unterschiedliche Ansichten, ne. Also äh,
zum Beispiel wir wir haben ja gesprochen über über Providerhaftung zum Beispiel, ne? Über ähm über Content Upload-Filter ähm und Ansipp zum Beispiel als Vizepräsident der Kommission,
verantwortlich für den digitalen Binnenmarkt hat hat klar gesagt, mit ihm kommt sowas nicht. Also es wird zum Beispiel auf keinen Fall ähm erst dagegen, dass die ähm E-Commerce-Richtlinie nochmal aufgemacht wird,
Dazu muss man sagen, dass die E-Commerce Richtlinie ähm was also dass die festlegt, dass Provider
und auch Plattformen nicht für den Inhalt haften, der bei ihnen veröffentlicht wird, bis sie davon Kenntnis haben. Das Übliche
Takedown. Ähm und das das steht ja gerade zur Diskussion, ob es eine Haftungserweiterung gibt für die Plattform. Er spricht sich klar dagegen aus. Dann kommst du zum nächsten Kommissar
da ist es dann nicht mehr so deutlich. Also Frau Jure war zum Beispiel, hatte ich, hatte ich den Eindruck, die sieht das ein bisschen anders. Ne, aber und sie ist aber auch, das fällt auch in ihrem Bereich.
Als Justizkommissarin und äh die Digitalkommissarin hat dann wieder eine etwas andere Ansicht dazu und ich bin also man hat,
Für mich war das das erste Mal so ein direkter Einblick darein, wie.
Unterschiedlich wie unterschiedlich die Perspektiven innerhalb der Kommission sind auf Dinge. Äh das kommt natürlich auch sehr darauf an, wo sie herkommt. An Sipp hat, wo sie herkommen. Ansiep hat ja auch darauf insistiert, zum Beispiel. Ähm ich komme aus,
äh aus einem aus einem Satellitenstaat der UDSSR quasi äh und äh ich bin es gewohnt
keine Meinungsfreiheit zu haben in einem sozialistischen Staat und deswegen ist sind zum Beispiel sind Verschärfungen der Haftung und auch Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit mir nicht zu machen.
Und dann kommst du zum nächsten Kommentar und der sagt na ja vielleicht müssen wir die Meinungsfreiheit ein bisschen einschränken. Also wie die sich dann einigen werden nicht bin ich mal sehr gespannt aber es geht,
ich finde, es hat einen Einblick daran gegeben, wie äh wie schwierig das sein muss, dort zu zu Kompromissen zu kommen in dieser Kommission.
Ich mein, das passiert natürlich nicht nur zwischen den oder weniger wahrscheinlich zwischen den Kommissaren als auf Arbeitsebene dann, ne? Also in, in den Referaten und so. Aber
Es muss wahnsinnig schwer sein. Und ich habe ehrlich gesagt ähm auch ein bisschen Respekt davor gewonnen, also äh.
Es wird ja immer gesagt, na dieser dieser Bürokrat, dieser riesen bürokratischer Parat, natürlich ist es ein bürokratischer Apparat, aber ich finde, man hat auch gemerkt, auch bei den Gesprächen, die wir außerhalb jetzt äh nicht nur mit den
Kommissaren, sondern auch mit anderen Menschen dort geführt haben. Ähm, dass dort schon mit Herzblut gerungen wird und dass das äh gar nicht so ein so ein Verknöcher der Beamten apparat ist, wie man zuerst mal denken kann. Ehrlich gesagt hat das bei mir auch immer äh dieser,
Verdrust auch immer, für den hat er auch immer Öttinger ein bisschen gesorgt, weil also Ottinger als Digitalkommissar war für mich, ich habe ihn einfach nicht ernst nehmen können, schon allein.
Grund sein, wenn er, wenn er halt Englisch spricht,
und seine Auftritte in der Öffentlichkeit. Ich habe ihn zum Beispiel einmal mit auf der Republika und äh so ich kann wirklich, ich konnte da nicht lange zuhören. Ich finde, also.
Hat alles dermaßen Lobby getrieben gewirkt, was er erzählt hat und äh da habe ich den Eindruck, dass da jetzt auch frischer Wind reinkommt durch die Maria Gabriel
Aber es ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder schwierig, ne? Wir wir waren jetzt da mit den Kommissaren gesprochen. Nächstes Jahr ist Europa ist Europawahl und danach sieht alles wieder ganz anders aus. Haben wir die Kommission ja auch wieder neu besetzt und keiner von denen weiß,
was von ihren Vorhaben eigentlich noch durchkommt und ob sie, äh, ob sie die Legislatur überleben und ob sie danach noch weitermachen können. Hm, das finde ich auch immer ein bisschen schwierig.
Was auf jeden Fall bei,
allen Kommissaren Durchklang war so Copyright, ja, das geht schon und vor allem Fernsehen, Fernsehen, Fernsehen, Fernsehen hatte ich so den Eindruck, weiß nicht, ob ihr das auch so gesehen habt, aber,
kam am laufenden Meter. Das Beispiel, dass man ja möglichst irgendwie seinen Fußball auch auf Mallorca äh gucken können darf und Streaming und so weiter, das muss ja alles möglich sein. Also dieses Entfernen von Sende und Streaming
Das war ja relativ klar, ne? Äh ich hatte dann auch noch so ein skurriles äh äh Randgespräch. Ähm.
Wo wir dann,
wo dann auch mal der Begriff Podcast da fiel und dann vom Gesprächspartner äh aufgegriffen wurde und irgendwie so nach einer Weile das Gefühl bekam, so.
Weißt du überhaupt, wovon du das, sonst bellte sich dann auch raus, dass da so die Wahrnehmung dieses Begriffs so überhaupt nicht verankert war
Gut, aber das spielt jetzt bei den Kommissaren überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Also Corpy Right und äh dieses ganz die ganze Frage von Lizenzklärung.
Die steckte überall drin, aber war auch eben auch nicht mehr als das, ne.
Auch da gibt's halt auch unterschiedliche Themenbereiche, die unterschiedlich stark äh von den Mitgliedsstaaten dann äh in die eine oder andere Richtung gedrängt werden
Im Grunde war das so ein bisschen einerseits einfach mal, also die ähm sozusagen der Hintergrund für für diesen für diese Einladung war wohl eben auch äh äh
Sogenannte digital Journalisten aus äh Deutschland, wahrscheinlich auch aus anderen Ländern Europas, hat ja auch geheißen
nach Brüssel zu holen, mal äh zu private Kontakte herzustellen, auch wenn die Meetings, das muss man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen, ähm leider auf der Record waren, äh, also sprich wir dürfen nicht darüber reden, aber da hatten wir noch auf, auf, zur Arbeitsebene, also mit so nieder.
Die mit den Kommissaren, ne? Also Kommissar war alles on the Record, alles andere war Hintergrundgespräch und von daher müssen wir uns da jetzt etwas schwammig und.
Aber es ging auf jeden Fall um den digitalen Binnenmarkt, das war eben nicht
nur Priorität oder einer der Prioritäten der Junckerkommission, die gerade im Amt ist, sondern eben natürlich genau diese Kommissare, äh mit denen wir dann tatsächlich gesprochen haben und eben mit den äh Beamten, mit denen es dann
auf der Record dann weiterging. Und ähm.
Es ist natürlich, also es gibt halt so diese vier Freiheiten der EU, äh die die überhaupt nicht in Frage stehen, schon seit Jahrzehnten irgendwie mehr oder weniger Alltag sind, also dass äh man waren halt nicht einfach hin und her schicken kann, dass man seinen Pass
ach okay, das ist jetzt Schengen, aber das wird eine andere Geschichte. Aber auf jeden Fall gibt's Freizüg, genau. Und eine Sache, die es halt eben wirklich ganz äh
äh und uns
Das war auch eben eine ganz große Priorität der Kommission. Darin lässt sich eben wirklich sehen, wie fragmentiert der digitale Binnenmarkt in Europa ist. Nämlich dieses leidige Geoblocking. Also sprich du bist in Deutschland, du willst auf irgendwas in Frankreich oder was oder umgekehrt, zugreifen, du siehst nichts
Äh das ist einerseits natürlich wichtig, um äh das abzuschaffen, um eben wirklich einen gemeinsamen digitalen Binnenmarkt zu schaffen. Das ist,
so heißt äh diese ganze Initiative. Äh das sind ja eben die fünfundzwanzig Vorhaben, die da die uns da verkauft wurden. Ähm.
Also einerseits als ganz konkrete, handfeste äh politische Sache, die durch und wirtschaftliche Sache, die durchgebracht werden muss. Aber natürlich.
Man muss diese Erfolge ja auch verkaufen und digitaler Binnenmarkt ging halt eben sehr abstrakt. Darunter kann sich wahrscheinlich niemand mehr irgendwas vorstellen. Äh der dann nicht tief in dieser Materie drinsteckt
Aber wenn man beispielsweise ein Deutscher ist und ein Netflix-Abo hat und dann nach Spanien in den Urlaub fährt und man kann dann plötzlich seine TV-Serie nicht mehr schaden oder sein Sky-Abo nicht mehr
dann kann man sich natürlich schon fragen, was macht diese blöde EU eigentlich? Warum ist das nicht abgeschafft? Warum kann ich da jetzt einfach mit dem Auto durch, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Länder fahren und alles geht und und von dort irgendwas bestellen und das geht auch, aber
Ich kann den digitalen, was ja wirklich das einfachste ist irgendwie, was man meinen würde. Äh,
dann muss man noch einmal mit den Fingern schnippen, irgendwo an der Einstellung auf dem Server von Netflix äh umlegen und uns die Sache sollte schon klappen. Äh und gerade in diesem Bereich äh hat sich die Kommission ziemlich weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt,
Das stand äh das war Bestandteil von mindestens drei EU-Richtlinien. Äh eben dieses Geoblocking auf allen möglichen und unmöglichen Ebenen abzuschaffen,
gerade was so audiovisuelle Sachen anbelangt ist, muss man sagen, die Kommission bislang auf voller Linie gescheitert
Also es gab dort zwar schon so kleine Verbesserungen. Äh das war letztes Jahr ist äh die Portabilitätsrichtlinie durchgegangen, äh das zum Beispiel ermöglicht es, ähm weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob die schon in Kraft ist, aber auf jeden Fall,
und nächsten Monaten. Äh aber auf jeden Fall äh ist es dann eben demnächst tatsächlich möglich, äh äh so Bezahlinhalte tatsächlich auch im EU-Ausland sozusagen.
Zu konsumieren. Äh es gab da eben auch noch eine andere ganz kleinen, so einen ganz kleinen Fortschritt, nämlich was ähm so.
Beiträge von öffentlichen Rechtlichen Sendern zum aktuellen Tagesgeschehen anbelangt. Auch die äh sind dann demnächst irgendwann vielleicht äh äh auch länderübergreifend dann zu sehen. Aber alles andere ähm.
Ist da da ist wirklich die Kommission angerannt gegen den Widerstand äh zum großen Teil der Mitgliedsstaaten, aber auch im EU-Parlament. Äh da hat die Filmindustrie definitiv noch Muskeln und Zähne und äh wehrt sich wirklich mit Händen und Füßen gegen jegliche Lockerung. Äh da geht's wirklich darum, Geschäftsmodelle äh zu schützen. Ich meine, äh es ist
auch so, dass die natürlich auch einen gewissen Case haben. Ähm also die Filmindustrie argumentiert beispielsweise, was was eben so,
ähm online mit der Theken äh betrifft und eben Rechte, die dann sozusagen komplett für den gesamten Binnenraum verhandelt werden. Was jetzt.
Nicht in diesen Verordnungen drin gestanden ist, aber das ist die Argumentation äh dann verlieren die bis zu zwanzig, dreißig Prozent äh ihres Jahresumsatzes. Das ist so die die Horrorbotschaft, äh die sie an die Wand malen und äh das ähm.
Hat sich offensichtlich zumindest, was einige Mitgliedsstaaten, so vor allem da was äh äh diese Audiovisuellen Sachen anbelangt ist, weil es Wissens äh,
Frankreich und äh Italien sind da ganz vorne dabei, das zu verhindern
äh aber auch im EU-Parlament zwischen wirklich oft gar nicht gewissen. Äh deswegen auch kein Zufall. Ähm also im ersten äh Gespräch mit Andros Ansieb, der
sozusagen der, das ist der federführende Kommissar für diesen ganzen Bereich, der ist auch der Vorgesetzte beispielsweise von von ähm Gabriel. Ähm der hat dann ausdrücklich drei
Richtlinien genannt, wo er wirklich
Zweifel hat, dass die noch durchkommen, beziehungsweise ich wollte nur noch festklopfen, aber dann ist er denn, sofort im Politikermodus umgeschaltet und man hat ja wird kämpfen bis zum Umfallen, aber er hat äh Zweifel, also Dows äh angemeldet äh bei der Cruparide-Richtlinie, also Urheberrecht
äh bei der sogenannten Cupsatt-Verordnung, das ist äh so eine äh Aktualisierung der Kabel und Satellitenverordnung, die jetzt eben auch noch im äh legislativen Prozess feststeckt äh und eben auch äh von der Lobby sozusagen ziemlich kaputt geschossen wird.
Und die dritte, das war der EC, das ist ähm European, Electronic Communication Codes, das ist auch so eine riesen Unterfangen, da redet man eigentlich auch, man ist Erachtens viel zu wenig darüber
gibt sich da heraus, dass es eben eine sehr komplizierte Thematik ist. Aber im Grunde geht's darum, da ordnet die Europäische Union das gesamte Rechtsgefüge,
oder einen großen Teil des Rechtsgefüges der Regulierung im Telekommunikationssektor neu.
Wie heißt dieser Code.
Abkürzung des EEC, European Electronic Communicationscodes läuft allgemein unter Kodex oder TK Review. Ähm,
Das hört sich alles sehr technisch, sehr regulatorisch, sehr abstrakt in weiter Ferne liegend an, äh entscheidet aber darüber, äh A.
Wird es überhaupt einen Glasfaserausbruch geben. Zweitens, wie schnell wird er über die Bühne gehen? Drittens und das ist aus meiner Sicht der Knackpunkt,
wird es da im Zuge dieser Reform zum Monopolenrespektive Olegupolen auf dem europäischen Telekommunikationssektor kommen. Das ist beispielsweise auch eine Initiative, die noch auf Günther Oettinger Juhu zurückzuführen ist
mit seinen erklärten Zielsetzungen, da hat er keine Hilde ausgemacht, ähm, möglichst groß, also möglichst wenige, zwangsläufig große, europäische IT, respektive Telekommunikationsanbieter zu schaffen
auf der einen Seite äh eben möglichst groß und stark sind äh in Europa, dass sie eben paar neuropäisch, also in gesamteuropa dann auch wirtschaftlich tätig sein können. Ähm.
Und auf der anderen Zeit des so großen, so mächtig sind,
dass sie sich auf dem Weltmarkt behaupten können, sprich eben auch expandieren in andere Gegenden und drittens, eben so groß und stark und reich zu sein, dass wir dann auch gegen, sozusagen, nennen wir es mal feindliche Übernahmen, äh nicht europäisch äh
Großbetriebe äh oder oder solche entsprechenden Konzerte geschützt sind,
Aber wenn man sich beispielsweise die Situation in den USA ansieht, dann ist äh wo eben der Markt zunehmend, also nicht nur zunehmend, also so. Es ist wirklich ein Dauerproblem von einer Handvoll von von Unternehmen, äh dominiert wird
wenn man so ein bisschen recherchiert und schaut, es gibt erstaunlicherweise
kaum Unternehmen, die mehr verhasst sind als äh ISPs, also also ähm Netzbetreibern, also vielleicht noch die Finanzbranche und und äh die Krankenversicherungsunternehmen, aber na ja.
Kommt schon ganz vorn.
Und und äh
und wenn alle wenn alle Stricke reißen und diese Reform schlecht ausgeht, dann dann könnten uns nicht sofort nicht von heute auf morgen und,
Wir kennen alle die Situation auf den deutschen Telekommunikationsmarkt, sowohl was band äh Breitband als auch Mobilfunk betrifft
Da droht tatsächlich äh dann möglicherweise eine eine rapide Verschlechterung da noch einzutreten. Also da hätten wir dann möglicherweise neue, also.
Ganze Marktliberalisierung in den achtziger und neunziger Jahren ist ja deswegen passiert, weil es ja.
Ähm nicht zu lagernde Probleme mit damaligen Staatsmonopolisten gab. Das hat man dann eben äh aufgelöst ähm äh bei einem
freien Markt und und ähm sozusagen ausgerufen und das hat zu Preis äh äh Nachläss und so weiter geführt
Jetzt dreht dreht sich so um der Wind, zumindest in der Europäischen Kommission äh und auch im Ministerrat muss man dazu sagen,
da hat das Parlament eine ganz andere Rolle ähm und uns Position. Also wir könnten.
Darin landen, dass wir halt keine staatlichen Monopole mehr haben, sondern private und das ist wirklich das letzte, was wir brauchen. Aber jetzt habe ich ein bisschen zu weit rausgeholt, Verzeihung.
Ja, Oligopole würde ich halt sagen, ne? Das ist das unsere unsere äh Realität, ne? So da noch was anzumerken, Holger, zu dem.
Nee, ich frage mich, ich habe mich nur gefragt, ähm ist denn, sind die äh.
Die EU regulatorisch befugt hier in den deutschen Markt soweit einzugreifen, dass sie bestimmt ähm ob zum Beispiel äh Telekommunikationsunternehmen privatisiert werden oder nicht.
Da kann sie nicht, oder?
Also diesen diesen Ansatz das also ich weiß es nicht genau ob das jetzt wirklich irgendwo tatsächlich oder so festgeklopft ist meines Wissen.
Sache des Staates des Einzelstaates, oder.
Prinzipiados erklärt beispielsweise auch warum äh direkt oder indirekt äh die Bundesrepublik Deutschland immer noch äh gut dreißig Prozent an der deutschen Telekom hält? Aber dieser marktbasierte Ansatz
der ist auf jeden Fall eine EU-Vorgabe, ja, noch aus den neunziger Jahren, also da kann die EU schon sagen, nö, äh, Staatsmonopolisten in dieser Form, wie sie halt in den sechziger, siebziger, achtziger Jahren existiert haben.
Dass es auf eine Initiative der EU äh zurückzuführen und auch dieser wettbewerbsbasierte Marktbasierte Ansatz beim Breitbandausbau
Das ist eine EU-Geschichte. Ganz im Detail kann die EU natürlich eben auch nicht reinregulieren, also da hat natürlich sowohl die Bundesregierung als auch die der entsprechende nationale Regulator in Deutschland. Das ist auch die Bundesnetzagentur. Einiges zu melden. Aber so dieses Rahmengefüge.
Äh was ist zum Beispiel ein äh äh ein marktmächtiger Akteur? Äh was ist eine signifikante Marktmacht.
Diese Definitionsfragen.
Das regelt die Europäische Union, die regelt eben auch was ist ein legitimes Kooperationsangebot, das ist dieser heißumstrittene Artikel vierundsiebzig im Kodex. Ähm, also ab wann muss ein.
Der Marktakteur, wenn er ein neues Glasfasernetz baut, andere äh in seine Netze lassen, ist es zulässig äh also genau diese kleinen Details, das wird tatsächlich auf EU-Ebene geregelt,
daran haben sich dann die Mitgliedschaften natürlich zu halten.
Ja, was auch noch so ein äh heiße, heiße Kartoffel war, ist äh das Leistungsschutzrecht, das äh kam ja auch irgendwie an den, an mehreren Stellen auch ähm.
Sagen wir mal auch so, es wurde auch am wildesten diskutiert, glaube ich, mit den anwesenden Journalisten. Das war so mein Eindruck.
Da hatte man auch den Eindruck, dass die anwesenden Journalisten mehr Ahnung von der Materie hatten, als die Kommissare.
Also die die Bürokratie wieder, die haben dann schon viel detailliertere Piruetten drehen müssen, um ihre Position zu legitimieren, ohne jetzt in Details einzugehen.
Ja, vor allem dachte ich auch immer, dass so wie die das so rübergebracht haben, war immer so, ja und wir wir tun ja was für für
Presse und das das muss doch alles in eurem Interesse sein und so und schaut uns immer so an, so nach dem Motto der gucke mal und sagen, dann können die Geldbeutel da lebt ihr noch von so und alle so im Raum so. Na ja, äh eigentlich
wenn wir das so nicht so geil und äh äh es kamen dann halt sehr viele Fragen auf so ähm.
Wie sieht denn da die Logik sehen in diesem ganzen Spiel und die Antworten waren nicht überzeugend. Das kann man, glaube ich, äh.
Formulierte.
Ja, genau, höflich formuliert sagen.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, man hat sehr eindeutig äh erkannt, wer die Antworten vorformuliert,
Also die waren ja teilweise wirklich vorformuliert. Und man hat halt auch, finde ich, gemerkt, zum Beispiel also bei,
hatte ich das Gefühl, dass er nicht hundertprozentig dahinter steht, was er sagt, ich kann mich irren, aber ähm er hat ja auch versucht, äh er kann mir dann auch äh mit dem,
mit den Soa Calls Lippeds und ähm und das das seid auch alles ganz okay und äh dann dann ging's ja um die Frage, wie viel ab, wie vielen wart denn da, bis zu wie vielen Wörtern ist es noch ein Snippert und dann ist das ein voller Text und so weiter. Ähm,
Und dann hat er, er kann, er kam ja dann mit äh mit dem mit dem Vergleich zwischen Musik und Presseverlagen und die Presseverlage müssen ja die Musik ähm müssen den Musik verlagen, dann kann man ja noch mit seinem äh ist nicht Dirigenten, den er so mag und so was. Also.
Es war das ja, das war so war alles so ein bisschen absurd und es klang halt wie äh ich muss das jetzt hier verteidigen,
tut mir leid.
Klang auch so ein bisschen so mit,
Ich habe die Schnauze eigentlich langsam voll. Einigt euch einfach mal überhaupt auf irgendwas so und so funktioniert's dann wahrscheinlich am Ende, ne? Am Ende sind dann einfach alle Exforstedt und wer am längsten durchgehalten hat, kriegt sie am meisten durch und äh ja.
Na ja, also zumindest äh an dem ganzen Bereich Copyright, also ähm was was die was die Rehe nicht Richtlinie jetzt angeht und die Verhandlungen dazu und äh auch was im Bereich Leistungsschutzrecht angeht. Man merkt halt echt einfach äh wie stark,
offensichtlich die Content-Lobby agiert und und da präsent ist in Brüssel,
Also das merkst du an allen Ecken und Enden. Es wirkt alles so vorformuliert, finde ich und äh teilweise einfach Positionen von den äh von den Content Vermarktern eins zu eins übernommen, auch äh auch was den audiovisuellen Bereich angeht, was du vorhin angesprochen hattest, auch mit äh.
Mit dem ganzen Geoblocking, ne? Also du hast echt
öfter gehört, ja wir würden ja gerne, aber das kriegen wir am besten will nicht durch gegen die Lobby so ungefähr, also das wird, finde ich, fand ich teilweise schon echt hart. Also, wie oft, wie, wie stark offensichtlich der Einfluss da ist.
Ja, der hat gerade bei dem Leistungsschutzrecht ähm,
was so ein bisschen bedenklich ist, ist das sozusagen das, was also ich finde das ohnehin ja schon bedenklich, dass das Thema überhaupt äh auf der europäischen Ebene gelandet ist, weil man dachte sich ja immer so, dieses Gesetz hat nun nicht unbedingt bewiesen.
Weiß denn, glaubst du, jeder deiner Hörerin und Hörer weiß, was das Leistungsschutzrecht ist oder sollten wir es nochmal kurz erklä.
Äh man kann's also einerseits ja, andererseits kann man's trotzdem nochmal äh.
Erläutern, wobei das zu erläutern ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so einfach, ne? Weil also das ist ja diese Idee, die von Springer aufgebracht wurde letztlich und dann auf deutscher äh in deutscher Gesetzgebung umgesetzt wurde
die quasi vorschreibt, dass äh auch so äh nur die reine Verlinkung und damit eben auch so die äh genutzten Ausschnitte, also teilweise halt
Titel und Teaser von Artikeln, dass die quasi auf Suchmaschinen verwendet werden, um auf dieser Artikel auf deren Seiten zu verlinken, dass das ja schon im Prinzip eine Copyright-Verletzung wäre und dafür müsste er dann irgendwie auch
bezahlt werden und man müsste das irgendwie lizenzieren und dann ging's lange hin und her
am Ende wurde das so durchgesetzt, sozusagen mit der Prämisse, na ja, jetzt fließt halt Geld zu den äh ähm
zu dem zu den Presseverlegern, weil ja ihre Inhalte genutzt werden
das hatte dann ähm ja im Prinzip zwei äh Effekte ein ähnliches Gesetz, was in Spanien in Kraft trat äh hat schlichtendes dazu geführt, dass Google News einfach eingestellt wurde, nach dem Motto, ja
bezahlt auch nicht dafür, dass wir auch noch irgendwie Geld ausgeben und auf euch verlinken, damit ihr da die Werbeeinnahmen haben kann. So, habt ihr sie noch alle
Deutschland ging's halt dann nicht ganz so weit, weil da hat sich die Presseverleger auch schon wussten, dass er dann ihre
einstellen können und dann haben sie halt einfach so Google und den ganzen, die halt die ganze Zeit im Kreuzfeuer waren, äh auch den Freibrief ausgestellt und gesagt, naja, dann kriegt der halt eine kostenlose Dezem
und.
Aber es gäbe die Möglichkeit.
Aber es gäbe die Möglichkeit, ne.
Pflichtige Lizenzen zu verteilen. Darum ging's ja.
Genau und in unserer Debatte kam ja dann auch immer wieder so diese äh kam ja immer wieder auf so, na ja, aber das ist ja äh quasi der Todesstoß für Start-ups, ja? Also wer auch immer in diesem Bereich News Vermittlung et cetera sich positionieren will
bleibt dann einfach nur noch Google über, weil gegen die kommt ihr ja eh nicht an und genauso ist es eigentlich auch gekommen und man hatte jetzt so ein wenig den Eindruck.
Wenn ich das mal so sagen darf, aus diesen ganzen Gesprächen, das.
Ist offensichtlich auch das Programm gewesen, ja? Äh dass man da gegen die großen nichts machen kann, ist klar, aber man konnte halt mit diesem Gesetz, was eigentlich eine ganz andere äh Zielrichtung hat.
Genau das bewirken nämlich, dass da eben überhaupt gar nicht erst andere Contender ankommen. Also im Prinzip ist es eine solidifiere Solidifizierung,
der Marktsituation, so, ne? Also man man brennt einfach das ein, was äh ist, um einfach Konkurrenz rauszuhalten und da muss man sich natürlich schon fragen, warum das auf nationaler Ebene,
Und insbesondere auf europäischer Ebene überhaupt ein Thema ist, ne? Trotzdem beschäftigt sich jetzt die EU-Kommission damit, hat auch noch einen eigenen Vorschlag, der,
dann um die Absurdität nochmal weiter zu treiben,
noch weitergehender ist also überhaupt keine Beschränkung mehr auf irgendwas hat, also es ist eigentlich der totale äh ähm der totale Copyright Wahnsinn und das ist dann sozusagen das Gegenangebot. Man bekommt so den Eindruck,
dass das äh jetzt quasi deshalb auf den Tisch gelegt wird, um sich dann am Ende auf die deutsche Situation zu einigen.
Ja, das denke ich auch. Also natürlich wird das nicht nicht so durchgehen, wie es im Moment vorgeschlagen ist. Aber es wird darauf rauslaufen, genau. Das äh das ist,
Ich glaube, das ist auch das Ziel. Man genau wie es in Deutschland auch war, eine eine völlig irrsinnige Forderung zu stellen und äh sich dann auf das zu einigen, was dann tatsächlich gekommen ist. Und äh das wird in Euro in Europa genauso laufen. Und ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, hatte ich jetzt den Eindruck, das geht auch durch
also das wird kommen.
Na ja
Also in dem Zusammenhang fand ich ja ganz lustig, äh äh als es eben darum ging, im Gespräch mit äh Ansieb äh der so die Unterschiede zwischen dem deutschen gescheiterten Leistungsschutzrecht und dem geplanten Europäischen äh irgendwie herauszuarbeiten
hat er dann bestritten, dass das überhaupt irgendwas äh zueinander zu tun hat. Das sind natürlich zwei ganz andere Geschichten und äh das europäische Leistungsschutzricht sei ja viel besser.
Unter anderem, deswegen, weil es den Schutz äh Zeitraum von, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht sehe, von zwei auf zwanzig Jahren oder so, äh, anheben.
Und äh so dann ein Argument nach dem anderen, also eine eine Verschärfung äh der deutschen Vorgaben äh der.
Und versucht habe, das eben als, als irgendwie,
Wohltat und in unserem Sinne äh herauszustellen, das ist eine Sache und die zweite Sache ist die, dass es gestern Abend eine aktuelle Entwicklung gegeben hat, äh, nämlich der Federführende Ausschuss im EU-Parlament
der Berichterstatter dort äh Axel Voss
hat's dann letztendlich äh sein, ist das ein Beruch ähm glaube ich äh vorgelegt. Ähm auf jeden Fall da ist selbstverständlich das Leistungsschutzrecht erhalten,
mindestens genauso schlimm auch Upload-Filter.
Äh die kamen da zumindest im äh äh im Zusammenhang mit der Urheberrechtsrinie gar nicht mal so sehr ins Gespräch, wurden zwar schon diskutiert, aber,
da war das Leistungsschutzrecht deutlich umkämpfter. Äh weil eigentlich so ein bisschen alle damit äh davon ausgegangen sind,
zumindest in der in der Urheberrechtsgerichtslinie die Uploadfilter jetzt nicht so die äh nicht mehr vorkommen werden. Da hat's also vorsichtige Anzeichen gegeben.
War das war ja auch noch unser Stand.
Genau und deswegen glaube ich.
Da wurde er wurde ja klar gesagt, also ähm das hatte man auch sehr deutlich rausgehört, dass äh dass es bei den Uploadfiltern jetzt erstmal vorrangig um äh um schwere Kriminalität und um Terror gehen soll und um das aus dem Netz zu kriegen, aber natürlich nicht im Urheberrech,
also erstaunt mich erstaunt mich jetzt auch, dass das äh dass das im Parlamentsvorschlag noch drin ist. Also das finde ich echt auch krass.
Ja, wobei das jetzt der Ausschuss noch nicht abgesegnet hat. Also man wird sehen, äh wie wie dann mit weiter vorgegangen wird, weil also da da gibt's mittlerweile ganz, ganz großen Widerstand. Unter anderem in diesem Bereich, da hat sich auch Ansieht mehr aus Unterstützung aus Deutschland gewünscht,
unter anderem hat er die Koalition ins B sozusagen äh hält sie Uploadfilter in diesem Bereich für nicht verhältnismäßig ähm ähm.
Äh also da kommt jetzt offensichtlich eben nicht nur Widerstand aus dem EU-Parlament, von den Einschlägen, Verdächtigen, sondern eben auch.
Deutschland. Und so, der Ministerrat, äh wir wissen, hat er dann doch eine gewichtige Rolle innerhalb der EU-Institutionen. Also diese Geschichte ist noch lang nicht ausgestanden.
Was übrigens an Sebastian auch gesagt hat, ne? Ich habe, ich habe gerade nochmal hier in meine Gesprächsnotizen geguckt. Er hat auch gesagt, Upload-Filter äh befürwortet er nicht, möchte er nicht, was er allerdings möchte, ist ähm Filter, die Dublin äh Content erk.
Will er schon. Und zwar im Copyright-Bereich.
Da muss man jetzt auseinander halten, da bin ich auch noch gerade dabei dann bitte noch eine Klarstellung von der Kommission zu halten, weil da kann sich hier wirklich niemand mehr aus. Es gibt da diese vorgeschlagenen Upload-Filter, ob die jetzt kommen oder nicht, sei dahin gestellt, in der U-Berichtslinien.
Dann gibt's aber eben diese
im großen im weitesten Sinne privatisierte Rechtszusetzung im Antiterrorkampf, äh das äh liegt eben nicht bei dieser Richtlinie, sondern bei Viello war
Und da gibt's ja so ein bisschen aufbauen auf so einer so einer losen, so einen Arbeitsgericht äh Kreis, das EU-Internetforum, das war so zweitausendfünfzehn einberufen. Äh da geht's in erster Linie um äh Entfernung mit automatisierten Systemen, sprich Datenbanken und Upload-Filtern.
Vom einschlägigen, was auch immer das ist terroristischen Content, also Jodova hat beispielsweise ein Tautobuch eben Tauptungsvideos angesprochen, aber das ist natürlich, solange das nicht ganz klar reformiert ist, eine problematische Sache.
Innerhalb dieser Arbeitsgruppe oder halt innerhalb dieser dieser Bemühungen der Kommission, also die die drohen ja ständig mit scharfen, legislativen Maßnahmen, hat auch hier Euro gesagt, das ist wahrscheinlich
was Terror betrifft, dazu kommen wird. Da drängen die ganz große Plattformbetreiber
dazu selbst eine Datenbank aufzubauen, die bereits in Kraft ist und zwar schon seit ungefähr eineinhalb Jahren oder so, ist im Betrieb. Äh da werden sogenannte Hesches, also digitale Finger ab,
von einmal als terroristisch identifizierten Inhalten eingespeist. Äh vielleicht auch noch wichtig, das sind dabei Facebook, YouTube, Microsoft
äh und das ist Google gewesen, dann auf jeden Fall ist auch diese vier, vier, fünf, richtig, richtig großen Plattformen. Äh twitter auch genau, also.
Neuerdings auch Instagram hat sie noch.
Und Google Plus genau richtig diesen Satz drei, vier Tagen oder so dabei. Also die befüttern so eine gemeinsam geführte Datenbank, da landen diese Hashes drin und äh
die wird dann auch gemeinsam abgefragt. Also sprich wenn jetzt irgendein Twitter-Nutzer irgendein so ein sagen wir's, nennen wir's mal Enthauptungswider rauflädst, das wird erkannt und gelöscht, landet dieser Hersteller in der Datenbank und wenn das jetzt einen Facebook-Nutzer versucht, nochmal hochzuladen.
Dann wird das eben ja unterbunden von diesem automatisierten System. Die Sache ist die, äh.
Besonders äh hervorgestellt wird eben genau dieser dieser Kampf gegen einschlägige Inhalte. Aber wenn man sich dann die Papiere genau ansieht, ähm
stehen da auch Urheberrechtsverletzungen drin,
Äh das heißt, es ist erstmal wirklich gar nicht klar, was soll, was ist jetzt wirklich die Priorität, äh weil man kann eben reinschreiben, was man möchte, aber das bedeutet nicht, dass es dann auch so genutzt wird, äh, wenn einem äh Urheberrechts oder halt einem Rechtsinhaber die Möglichkeit eingerahmt wird
genau so einen äh beanstandeten Inhalt zu melden und das landet in dieser Datenbank, ist es de facto ein Uploadfilter.
Auch wenn jetzt auf Selbstregulierung passiert und jetzt kann ich mal mit einer legislativen Maßnahme jetzt irgendwie abgesichert ist,
was das Ganze nochmal ein bisschen problematischer macht, weil das da können dann die Plattformen, die haben halt sehr viel Spielraum und vor allem, wenn's dort keine guten Repress-Möglichkeiten, also halt äh so ein so eine Klagemöglichkeiten oder
was auch immer so Möglichkeiten für Verbraucher und Nutzer gibt, ähm sich dagegen ungerechtfertigte Löschung.
Zu wehren und zwar so, dass es halt auch entsprechende Fristen gibt oder eben
klar definierte Wege, äh auch Zeiträume, die innerhalb innerhalb äh derer entsprechenden Plattformen andere agieren müssen, auch solche Eingaben, dann ist natürlich ein
Zensur, Tür und Tor geöffnet, einer privatisierten Rechtsdurchsetzung, das sind natürlich höchstproblematisch ist.
Und natürlich besteht dann auch die Möglichkeit schaffen wir uns dann mehrere parallel irgendwie so Welten oder Parallelsysteme,
das ist etwas, worauf ich jetzt noch auf die Antwort der Kommission warte, da wurde mir gestern beschrieben, sie wüssten's nicht und äh geben wir heute hoffentlich.
Äh dass du meinst mehrere verschiedene Filtersysteme oder.
Exakt genau oder landet das alles in dieser privaten Datenbank? Das wäre natürlich auch möglich, weil die Gefahr, also was ja diskutiert wird im Rahmen der Urüberrechtslinie, dass es ja darauf hinauslauft, dass alle Plattformenbetreiber de facto auf Content ID von YouTube zurück.
Genau, das habe ich auch so verstanden. So hat sich das immer angehört. Das wurde so oft genannt.
Ja, ja, aber das ist doch einigermaßen absurd, oder? Dann hat man da äh also kommt dann an die deswegen vielleicht noch die Überlegung ist,
Google ist ein mega Konzern, die haben extrem viel Kohle, die haben die technischen äh Ressourcen und Möglichkeiten so ein System auf die Beine zu stellen,
mehr oder weniger gut diese Inhalte dann erkennt, ähm jetzt mal komplett unabhängig davon, wie gut das jetzt wirklich funktioniert.
Kleinere Plattformanbieter, die mit einer Richtlinie oder Verordnung dazu gezwungen werden oder eben auch ähm also äh Non-Profit-Organisationen wie Wiki Media zum Beispiel,
Äh auch Uploadfilter einzusetzen, die können entweder sowas selbst entwickeln, was aber natürlich enorm teuer ist, Zeit in Anspruch nehmt äh und,
ja vielleicht wurde das Geld woanders besser aufgehoben wäre, das würde ähm darauf hinauslaufen, dass die sich an ein bestehendes System einer privatwirtschaftlichen Firma wie zum Beispiel Google dann anschließen und kontinuierlich verwen.
Oder eben dann diese angebliche äh Antiterrordatenbank äh zur zur Hilfe genommen wird, wo es eigentlich erst im Moment Hauptungsvideos ging, aber wo eindeutig drinsteht, wenn man die Kommissions- und die Hartzpapiere liest und Empfehlungen liest.
Bitte, das gilt auch für Urheberrechtsverletzungen. Also das ist ein wirr, wahre.
Das ist dieses Microsoft System, ne.
Das es wird es wird von ist es glaube ich nicht wenn ich richtig informiert bin ist das noch nicht offiziell bekannt gegeben was dahinter steckt aber ich glaub Fotos sind oder so heißt das von Microsof.
Ja genau, da das ist ja eigentlich entwickelt worden, um äh,
doppel Kinderpornografische Inhalte aus dem Netz zu kriegen. Und was wird wird ja von Microsoft in den USA auch schon sehr sehr eifrig eingesetzt? Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Also wenn du wenn du in den USA auf One Drive irgendwie wenn da jemand einen knapp.
In der Pornografie, Bild oder Video hochlädt ähm die die One Drive Laufwerke werden automatisch gescannt und dann geht auch die Anzeige automatisch raus, die Strafanzeige, an die Strafverfolgungsbehörden, wenn so ein Bild erkannt wird aus äh mit dem Datenbankabgleich,
Das ist mittlerweile in USA vollautomatisiert. Ich weiß nicht, also.
Das kam auch sehr deutlich raus für meine Begriffe. Ähm es gibt eine klare Priorisierung. Also und das, das ist halt auch äh was die Öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit angeht.
Wenn es um die Durchsetzung von solchen Themen geht, wie wie Content-Filter zum Beispiel oder Upload-Filter, dann verfallen immer zuerst durch die Stichworte Terror und Kinderpornografie,
Kindermissbrauchsdarstellungen. Ähm und auf dem Rücken von diesen.
Unstrittig schweren Straftaten, ne? Äh.
Werden dann eben geht's dann in andere Bereiche, also was mich sehr erstaunt hat bei dem Gespräch mit Jo war auch ist wie sehr sie das alles vermengt hat.
Also zum Beispiel hat sie sehr oft äh davon von Hate Speech gesprochen, aber ähm hat.
Dann ging es wieder um um Copywith Inhalte, dann ging es aber wieder um Äußerungsdelikte, also um eindeutig illegale Delik.
Aber Hate Speech zum Beispiel, es ging ist dann aber auch immer wieder der Begriff Hate Speeds gefallen, auch im im Zusammenhang mit Content-Filterung. Aber Headspeach ist nicht strafbar. Das das finde ich ein bisschen problematisch. Es ging dann wieder um Illegal Content, dann ging's wieder um Hate Speech,
dann ging's wieder um die ganz schweren Sachen. Ähm aber
ich glaube einfach, dass die Gefahr da ist, dass wenn solche solche Systeme einmal da sind, dass sie dann werden eben die Anwendungszwecke ausgeweitet zwangsläufig, ne. Also,
bei Terror fängt's an, dann kommt Urheberrecht und dann wird halt irgendwann gesagt
Oh, ja, aber ähm wenn wir, wenn wir jetzt gute Texterkennungsalgorithmen haben, dann könnte könnte man natürlich auch automatisch nach Hate Speech in den Netzwerken suchen lassen und äh und äh auf also auf den großen Äußerungsplattformen
das dann auch automatisiert schon vorm Upload rausfiltern und dann wird's wirklich ganz hart, finde ich.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Beigeschmack, den man da bekommen hat, obwohl viel über Single Market geredet wird, es ist am Ende alles wieder eine große Copyright-Durchsetzungs äh und eben auch Antimarktliberalisierung, weil eigentlich hier sehr viel
sehr viel mehr Anklang über das Erhalten und Retten alter Geschäftsmodelle. Gab dann und ein Mittagessen auch nochmal so eine ganz.
Debatte so in diese Richtung, so ob.
Ob sie sich denn eigentlich im Wesentlichen alle nur mit der Erhaltung alter Geschäftsmodelle äh beschäftigen würden, während halt die Amerikaner mit neuen kommen und nicht wirklich einfach auch mal die Gelegenheit sehen, neue Geschäftsmodelle äh auch in Europa zu befördern.
Ja, war da so ein bisschen Ratlosigkeit auf der anderen äh Seite, ob dieses Arguments. Also.
Andererseits, also was ich was mir auch so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten gemacht hat beim Fragen.
Gerade bei diesen Hintergrundgesprächen war dann auch oft so dieses OK jetzt würdest du eigentlich ganz gerne diese oder jene Policy hier mal irgendwie genauer hinterfragen, warum man es denn nicht so oder so macht.
War mir dann immer auch klar, okay diese Leute da sind eigentlich auch nur so katalysatoren der nationalen Regierung und die
so richtig dieses eigene Agenda-Setting ist sehr schwierig, man merkt einfach, dass sie quasi die ganze Zeit im Wesentlichen diese Positionen.
Ja, aller oder vielleicht auch nur einzelner Staaten dort äh irgendwie einbringen. Man hat auch oft so den Eindruck eben,
stark doch der Einfluss der großen Staaten ist, insbesondere Deutschland, wie sie da jetzt alle so sitzen und auf die neue Koalition warten, so, ja, so ein bisschen so das Karnickel da irgendwie Jan, macht doch endlich mal die Koalition, damit wir wieder wissen,
was jetzt eigentlich die die Rahmen sind, die Richtlinien sind, in denen wir hier weiterverhandeln können, ne? Und da kann man ihnen natürlich jetzt auch keinen Vorwurf machen, weil,
Das ist nun mal so, dafür ist die Kommission da, es ist nicht die Regierung, es ist die Kommission, aber das ähm
War dann eben auch ein bisschen schwierig da zu debattieren, ne, weil sie ja natürlich jederzeit damit argumentieren können, na ja, aber will's keiner fordern.
Ne, also man kann das ja auch irgendwie nicht unsere Position sein. Also das ist auch so das, wo ich mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher bin, inwiefern eine eine Kommission, eigentlich überhaupt eine Chance hat, ein eigenes Agenda-Setting zu betreiben.
Na ja, vielleicht einschränken dazugesagt, gerade im Bereich von Geo Bocking sieht man da, die äh äh Kommission tatsächlich versucht, eine eigene Agenda gegen den Widerstand der Mitgliedstaaten zu starten, um das halt äh zumindest in dem Bereich.
Aber wirklich gegen den Widerstand aller Staaten.
Nö, nee, also es gibt da natürlich schon äh einige Staaten, die da ganz anderes und liberaler mit solchen Sachen umgehen. Ähm aber trotzdem, wenn schon im Vorfeld äh sichtbar ist, dass da die drei, vier Großen dagegen sind, äh dann.
Ist das erstmal nicht so populär.
Ist nicht so populär und äh gute Kommission hat natürlich durch das EU-Institutionsgefüge eine nicht einfache Rolle. Äh da gilt es sehr viele Interessen
gegeneinander auszuspielen und dann ist man eben auch nicht so stark, wie man gern wäre und das ist auch
gar nicht mal so schlecht, äh aber sagt die Frage, wer dann, wer denn wirklich am äh längeren Hebel sitzt, aber
Zum Beispiel, also um das jetzt wirklich vorbildhaft da raus zu picken, äh da hat sie es versucht in dem Bereich und es hat sich an der blutigen Nase geholt bis
jetzt, also man sieht, vielleicht wird's ja mit der Kapsel-Verordnung anders, aber na ja.
So, ich glaube euer beider Zeitkontingent äh geht zum Ende, weiß nicht, habt ihr noch irgendwie zum Abschluss noch irgendwas abrundendes zu diesem Besuch zu sagen.
Ich. Mhm.
Was abrundendes Asyl. Wir sind ja zusammen am Flughafen gut gewesen und gut nach Hause gekommen. Und Tim und ich haben uns auch noch ein Löffel gegönnt.
Ich als Alter nicht trinke. Ich war so.
Nein, also ich ich also da muss ich auch nochmal ein bisschen eine Lanze für die Kommission berechnen oder überhaupt, für die EU. Ich finde es sehr gut. Also ich finde
Wir haben in Deutschland die Situation gerade. Ich weiß nicht, wie es in anderen Staaten ist, weil ich so war ich relativ wenig äh ausländische Presse lese, aber ich finde, wir sind hier in Deutschland, was die Berichterstattung angeht, die politische Berichterstattung viel zu sehr auf Berlin und auf Deutschland fixiert. Ähm und,
dort.
Also das haben wir halt jetzt auch wieder in den zwei Tagen gesehen. Dort wird unheimlich viel gemacht und auch dort wird unheimlich viel äh äh darüber bestimmt, wie hier zukünftig oder die Rahmenbedingungen für die deutsche Politik auszusehen haben.
Das findet finde ich viel zu wenig Beachtung. Also wenn du auch siehst.
Lea zum Beispiel dieses dieses Pressebriefing war, wir waren ja dann mittags in der täglichen Pressekonferenz. Äh ich finde, das war alles so eine, so eine ritualisierte Zahnlose Veranstaltung, so ein bisschen und da,
ich finde die das es ist auch Aufgabe der deutschen Medien,
mehr, mehr in die EU reinzuhören und in die Institutionen reinzuhören und zu gucken, was da abläuft. Ich finde, auch berichterstattungsmäßig
passiert zu wenig, was so. Es gibt halt immer im öffentlichen Rechtlichen gibt's ja zum Beispiel diese eigenen Europasendungen oder so. Aber wer guckt das schon? Also ich finde nachrichtenmäßig zum Beispiel
fixiert man sich jetzt viel zu sehr auf die neue Regierung anstatt auch mal zu gucken, was Macron europäisch vorschlägt und äh und was im Koalitionspapier auch zu zum Thema Europa drinsteht,
wird findet, findet, finde ich zu wenig Beachtung,
Aber na gut und deswegen finde ich das sehr ehrenwert und sehr lobenswert, dass die uns dann, dass sie sich die Mühe machen, uns einzuladen für uns ein Programm zusammenzustellen und uns auch die Gelegenheit geben, mal direkt äh mit ein paar Kommissaren zu.
Äh es finde ich sehr gut und das machen die ja, so wie ich das verstanden habe, es war ja auch eine eine spanische Digitaljournalisten äh Delegation schon da und glaube ich auch eine französische.
Wir waren glaube ich die mit der größten Mannstärke, so wie ich das verstanden habe. Aber ich find's gut, dass sie es machen. Also und es soll ja nächstes Jahr wieder stattfinden und ich äh da würde ich mich sehr freuen, da wieder auf einen aktuellen Stand gebracht zu werden.
Na ja.
Also ich hab's eben auch sehr genossen, es ist eben sehr spannend, gerade im äh nicht nur mit den Kommissaren zu reden, sondern vor allem auch mit den Leuten.
Tatsächlich äh dann dann in den Verhandlungen mit den äh mit
Parlamentariern oder mit den Mitgliedsländern dann effektiv drinstecken, im Trilog beispielsweise ähm.
Definitiv mehr europäische Berichterstattung, das gilt insbesondere für öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk äh und auch äh natürlich auch andere Medien. Wenn jetzt Politik Punkt org versuchen wir schon, wenn das zwangsläufig ist oder kommen wir nicht hinaus.
Sehr gut, finde ich. Ja.
Dankeschön. Äh auch wenn's immer sehr oder nicht immer, aber in der Regel sehr schwer ist, das zu vermitteln. Ähm.
Für uns das man kann sich dann auch sehr in Details verrennen, nicht nur was jetzt dann einzelne Policy betrifft, sondern auch erklärt man jetzt, was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem Europaraten, dem
Rathaus, aber da geht man doch schon von einem Vorwissen aus oder nicht, aber da hat auch definitiv die EU ein Imageproblem oder oder ja, da könnte sie auch noch für mehr Klarheit suchen, an vorhin eine Benennung und und Auszeichnung,
Aber gut, das ist jetzt eine lange Debatte
können wir uns diese Datum nicht mehr einlassen. Prinzipiell fand ich's eben sehr spannend, äh sehr gut. Ähm dass auch die Kommission äh der Versuch so ein bisschen ähm äh den
zu Journalisten herzustellen, aber eben auch
man könnte fast sagen, so großzügig ist unter Anführungsstrichen jetzt nicht nur ihre eigene Perspektive dadurch schämen zu lassen, also sie hätte uns ja nicht äh den Kontakt zur EU-Parlamentariern vermitteln müssen
uns die wurden ja auch nicht von der Kommission ausgewählt, sondern vom europäischen Parlament, also das war, fand ich eigentlich auch ganz gut. Ähm,
ja gerne wieder. Äh.
Gerne auch wieder mit euch.
Definitiv.
Vielleicht auch nochmal von mir nochmal so zwei Cent, also ich fand besonders die Begegnung mit der auf der Parlaments mit dem EU-Parlamentsvertretern äh extrem belebend, da hatten die Gespräche.
Deutlich mehr.
Substanz vielleicht, also sie waren direkter extrem informativer, da konnte ich sehr viel mehr rauslesen und man merkt da auch oder ich glaubte zumindest zu merken, was Europa braucht, ist einfach ein stärkeres Parlament.
Der Einfluss, der Einfluss äh äh dieses äh dieses Gremiums, also wenn wenn hier die
ähm die Bewaffnung einfach anders wäre, wenn das Parlament einfach Initiativrecht hat oder was weiß ich sogar vielleicht Initiativen der Kommission auch komplett.
Begraben kann, dass es nicht klar ist, da kommt auf jeden Fall was, wenn man sagt so, nee, das fassen wir gar nicht erst an. Irgendwie, also einfach mehr äh Handels äh Fähigkeit an der Stelle. Das würde dem gesamten Prozess extrem gut tun
Weil derzeit ist das alles im Wesentlichen alles am Ende hat man das Gefühl, das ist der Ministerrat, also sprich die Vertretung der nationalen Regierung in der EU
irgendwie den Rahmen dann letzten Endes doch vorgeben und auch wenn das natürlich verständlich ist, ob dieses ähm.
Teilförderalen Systems denke ich mal, müssen wir da langfristig einfach woanders hinkommen und das konnte man auch bei dieser Reise gut rauslesen.
So viel dann vielleicht zur äh EU, dann wissen wir jetzt endlich mal, was sie für uns äh getan hat und äh.
Oh noch nicht.
Oder auch nicht äh Holger, vielen Dank nach Hannover, für deinen Beteiligung.
Ja, schöne Grüße.
Und auch danke an Thomas hier im Studio und ja vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, das war's. Log Punkt Netzpolitik zweihundertvierundvierzig nächste Woche dann bestimmt wieder mit Linus und äh ich sage tschüss und bis bald.